god help me hey guys i'm abby short
welcome to ali's kitchen and i'm here
with my friend Abbi Langer so we are
back we had so much fun last time trying
out some of those disgusting diets that
you guys suggested that we try so we are
back with some of the craziest celebrity
endorsed diets and you're not gonna want
to miss this oh my god so we're gonna
kick things off with Gwyneth Paltrow's
favorite smoothie from her goop
so this is from one of her three day
food cleanses this is pretty much the
only smoothie that we could afford my
client Paltrow Misa some bone broth so
trending social salts yeah cuz you need
more salt with the bone broth and the
miso and a nice avocado for texture her
texture and color and healthy fats
this actually looks like vomit this is
like I'm not baby diarrhea are you so so
nervous about this okay it's gross
it's like it's just coats your palate
and I don't know if it's gonna go away
for a long long time it's revolting okay
I actually love to do I love to see
Gwyneth Paltrow smoke crack I would
rather die than let my kid eat cuppa
soup that's a little extreme just a
little extreme when like come on like
why don't you use your fame and your
money to help people who really can only
access things like cup of soup and I
should like cup of sir when I pass a
flowery zucchini plant in a garden my
heart skips a beat she needs to get laid
like come on if the most exciting part
of your day is seeing a [ __ ] zucchini
flower there's something going wrong
yeah yeah this one's from Khloe
Kardashian which we know is generally
[ __ ]
I didn't sleep last night because I was
thinking about did having to do this I
was like I am genuinely concerned but
she takes a TSP of ghee every morning
ghee is clarified butter she waits 20
minutes then she eats food it revs up
your fat metabolism so you burn your fat
as fuel oh my god it's great
chunky why
oh that's its no don't feed me it's oily
and grainy at any time I didn't think it
was possible the whole concept here is
that he is high in butyric acid which is
a short chain fatty acid and actually
research has shown that it has some
benefits for people with IBS and GI
issues but not for fat metabolism fat
burning nobody burns fat so now we get
that that's traveled right away listen
we love cooking you fat we love it on
arm yeah yeah this is not gonna help you
lose weight no it's not even pleasurable
butter speaking pleasurable food should
be pleasure yeah yeah all right finally
activated charcoal my body tells me
doctor I know like I'm pretty sure this
is something like my mother would have
said way back in the day with you see
something black don't put it in your
mouth Jacek lemonade it does like what
it looks like it honestly does but I
wouldn't want to say is that this bottle
of this was $12 $12 for something that
is basically just kind of lemon water
but probably some sweetener basically
the way it works is that these the
charcoal basically has these kind of
it's like a sponge like surface and it
sucks up any toxins but the thing is it
only works for the toxins that are still
inside your stomach but here's the
here's the kicker activated charcoal
does not discriminate so while it may
suck up the toxins and the poisons it's
also going to suck up all those
important nutrients that you just put in
your body that you just paid twelve
fifteen dollars for and out she goes you
didn't even get to reap the benefits of
any of those nutrients do not eat
charcoal don't use charcoal to grill
some yeah let's wait if you're going
into the hospital and you're about to
die because you've poisoned yourself and
you use charcoal to detox you that's a
hell of a lot different than why
down the street with charcoal sugar
water those are clinical scenarios that
are pretty extreme yeah your doctor's
not gonna prescribe a lemonade with a
little bit of this like black substance
in it as a way to detox you because
there's no science to back it up
plus it's just a [ __ ] waste to your
money so don't spend that $12 on you
know on a nice brunch Oh with the girls
yeah pancakes great now I'm gonna be
[ __ ] black charcoal at tonight have
a few addy can't wait even water though
you owe us one big time so if you've got
a great diet that you want us to try out
please be nice to us please please
please leave us a comment below
we would love to hear what kind of crazy
[ __ ] you've been hearing about or trying
out thanks so much for watching be sure
to subscribe to my channel like this
video and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen oh god Winnie you are
just disgusting
you